the highest-ranking drug company
executive convicted in the opioid crisis
is headed to prison but the sentence is
not harsh enough for some who say he got
away with murder a judge sentenced iNSYS
therapeutics founder John Kapur to five
and a half years for his role in bribing
doctors to prescribe the powerful
painkiller subsys our consumer
investigative correspondent and a Werner
is in Boston where Kapoor was sentenced
and a good morning good morning well
yeah he was a highly successful
billionaire who founded a drug company
but yesterday he arrived here as a man
trying to avoid a long prison sentence
76 year-old john kapoor came to court to
ask the judge for a lighter sentence
during a hearing where seven victims
were their relatives told how his
company's drug subsys destroyed their
lives people like deb fuller whose
thirty two-year-old daughter Sarah
died of an overdose after taking the
drug I'm doing this for Terry because
she deserves to be heard
and since she can't be here herself then
I will be here for so that you know he
can hear just how he destroyed her life
our lives Kapoor was convicted for mail
and wire fraud for his part and what
prosecutors said was a nationwide
conspiracy to boost sales of subsys by
bribing doctors to prescribe the drug to
patients who should never have received
it the drug was only approved by the FDA
for breakthrough cancer pain FDA data
shows more than 8,000 people died after
taking subsys yesterday a packed
courtroom watched as Kippur turned to
the victims and told them I'm so sorry
for your suffering I can feel it
prosecutors had asked for a 15 year
sentence the judge gave him five and a
half years what do you think of the
sentence that was given him his time for
don't think it was fair wasn't fair to
all the victims later we spoke with
prosecutors including assistant US
attorney NAT Yeager I was offended by by
John Kapoor's statement I don't see how
anyone would listen to what he had to
say and believe him I thought his words
rang hollow I think that he was
absolutely driven by greed by the desire
for money the desire of being the best
in the industry and I don't think he
cared at all about the patients during
trial last year prosecutors showed a
video featuring company employees
rapping about increasing sales one was
former vice president of sales Alec
burakov dressed as a life-sized version
of the company's painkiller yesterday he
too was sentenced to a shorter term of
26 months in prison reflecting the fact
that he cooperated with prosecutors
to relatives of people who passed away
due to use of senses in all this week
Berlocq often for other executives
received sentences ranging from a year
and a day to 33 months they and Kapoor
will go to prison but not long enough
for many families they all got away with
murder because that's exactly what they
did because there's more than Sarah that
died from it
prosecutors told us last night they do
believe that this trial which used RICO
conspiracy statutes traditionally used
to prosecute mob bosses against the
company and its executives will make a
positive difference in future
prosecutions of opioid cases Tony would
be the first of many and I thank you
very much